واعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه سيطره قواتها
بشكل كامل على مدينه نوفودونيتسكا في
مقاطعه وقالت وزاره الدفاع ان القوات
الروسيه صدت هجوما اوكرانيا ودمرت نحو 50
اليه ودبابه اوكرانيه خلال القتال
نعم جلال ما تقوله القوات الروسيه انها
تصد كل الهجمات التي تقوم بها القوات
الاوكرانيه على عدد من المحاور على
دانيالات النصيب الاكبر من هذه الهجمات
سبع هجمات اوكرانيه وهجمتان في اتجاه
زبروجيا اما فيما خاص فهي امتداد هذا
الامتداد بين مقاطعه
المعارك هذا هكذا يوصفها المتحدث باسم
وزاره الدفاع
هذه المنطقه اذا ما تحدثنا تفصيلا في
المعطيات الميدانيه التي اكنت تنشرها
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه او حتى المواقع
العسكريه الروسيه يجري الحديث عن جبهتي
مارينكا واولدار جنوب مدينه دنيتك وهذا
الامتداد كما قلنا عند التقاطع بين
دانيت وصولا الى اريخافا اليوم الحديث
هذه المنطقه اليوم تتبادل السيطره عليها
القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه دارت تقول
اكواد الروسيه انها تسيطر عليها ثم تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه وتؤكد سيطرتها عليها
اليوم اخر المعطيات التي تحدث عنها موقع
ريبار العسكري الروسيه يقولوا ان القوات
الروسيه اليوم تتموضع عند مواقع مرتفعه في
هذه المنطقه ما يضع القوات الاوكرانيه ما
يضعها في موقع وفي خانه المحاصره ولم تعد
قادره على الدفاع عن نفس هذه الجبهات
والحديث عن القرى والامطار اما التقدم او
حتى التراجع فيما يسمى بالمنطقه الرماديه
باتت منطقه كر وفر هذه المنطقه وايضا باتت
يستعر فيها القتال بشكل كبير خطوط
المواجهه ما زالت ثابته منذ اسبوعين بدا
هذا الهجوم المضاد ولم تتغير المعطيات
الميدانيه كثيرا جلال في ما خاص الجبهات
الاخرى افدي افكا اي يتم الحديث من قبل
المواقع العسكريه الروسيه عن تقدم بطيء
يمكن القول للقوات الروسيه في شمال دنيتك
هذا الامر ترده او مرده الى ان هذه
المنطقه فيها تحصينات اوكرانيا منذ تسع
سنوات